and then the mayor of Cincinnati tweeted
this in responses yeah deserve that
congrats to Casey on a well-fought win
and good luck in Arizona proud of our
fans and our Bengals for the energy all
year so Jesse yeah had a good time had a
good time uh my voice is shot I was the
12th man
I want to explain the controversy over
why I wasn't wearing green because
there's a reason
controversy a lot of controversy my
daughter shamed me because she said
where's your merch dad and I wasn't
wearing merch because I was staying at a
place that had a dress code so the place
I was staying at in Philly you weren't
allowed to kind of wander around in and
out with your face green or your jersey
on not that type of establishment wow
fancy what kind of stuff I'm not going
to talk about where I stayed it's not a
business also Red Roof this is Red Roof
wasn't it other controversies occurred
during the game
I was down in very good seats but all of
a sudden the Jumbotron shows Bradley
Cooper in a suite and his name goes up
and the whole crowd goes crazy now I was
also with the game Fox covered the game
they knew I was at the game they didn't
decide to show me they didn't put my
name up there and that's fine I don't
need to be in a suite I'm happy to be
down with the fans third controversy
yeah
I got wings and I got boneless wings at
the Wing Zone and they were excellent a
lot of people gave me a hard time
because they said boneless wings don't
exist in real life they said you have to
have the bone in the wing we report you
decide I thought they were scrumptious
and I'm not going to be eating Wings off
the bone in the middle of the game just
pop them in your mouth right and that's
the move I agree also
I'm a good luck charm I've never been to
an Eagles game where we have lost so if
anybody wants to invite me to the Super
Bowl and pay for private flights or
tickets I'm in and I want to make a
wager with Harris Faulkner who I heard
as a Chiefs fan for ten thousand dollars
of Harold fort's money
in the game I don't even care what the
spread is
straight up uh Steve Deuce you want to
take him on too he's a Kansas City yep
bring it on again another 10 000 Heralds
money all right well um your voice is uh
needing a little rest but it's better
than Mahomes voice I don't know is that
is just his voice
they're not allowed to eat wings at this
place you stayed also
did you have to have like did they have
linen napkins I didn't bring the food
back Harold what'd you make of the game
um I understand why Hammer was was upset
that that cult in the game was the right
call but there were a lot of calls in
that game but uh without question the
the the Chiefs got fired up by with the
Bengals and their fans and the mayor
said and Patrick Mahomes put on put on a
show I'm gonna let my pal gutfel defend
the 49ers but I'll say this the 49ers
didn't have a quarterback most of the
game
um but I gave her his shoulder and then
we gave the other guy a concussion no
doubt about it but you have to go
concussion now you have to give credit
to it because you have to give credit to
your offense the 49ers defense number
one in the league
um you all destroyed them and you you've
shown you can pass you can run it's
going to be a great Super Bowl uh this
matchup the thing I'm most excited about
the next 10 years in the NFL we got
young quarterbacks Justin Herbert didn't
make it that Prescott didn't make it uh
in the borough Mahomes lineup is going
to be so awesome over the next few the
next few years in the 49ers you guys
just got to decide on which of the three
quarterbacks you want because you got
three great ones two of them will
probably be traded one will probably be
traded next year and go to another team
which will make make it even more
interesting judge did you watch the
games yesterday well let me say this
don't blame February 12th
it's going to be
the most incredible day it's a day that
I've been waiting for all year I am
looking forward to it it's the beginning
of Fashion Week in New York city so I
will be in a fashion show on February
12th but let me just say one thing about
the the Empire State Building green and
white even I get it okay that is
Blasphemous it is treason it is aiding
and abetting it's all bad stuff and I'm
ashamed let me show you here so the
Empire State Building all of a sudden
last night after the Eagles won that
game they it lit up green and white and
they tweeted this Fly Eagles Fly we're
going green and white in honor of the
Eagles NFC Championship Victory and the
New York Post cover was bird brain's
off-color Empire mistake building lights
up for the Eagles and there's a mob
assembled at the Empire State Building
and demanded that the the lights be
taken down and the person who tweeted it
to be fired or who decided to be fired
no word yet on whether they were fired
Greg do you want to defend the 49ers no
you know actually uh I don't really
watch a lot of football anymore when I I
started to kind of fall out of love is
when I became older than the players and
then when I became older than the
coaches I felt like what am I doing
watching this and then I'm looking at
the players and they all look like
members of boy bands so I figured this
sport was not for me but I do want to
comment on uh I helped Jesse with his uh
his Eagles uh analysis it's not a Wii
it's them they don't like you Jesse
those the eagles they don't like you the
Eagles don't like it you know they don't
like you the players yeah they hate you
no no no no no I have it on good faith
that they can't stand you and a lot of
people don't like you a lot of people
don't like you but let's not make it
about you let's make it about the reason
why the Eagles are so unpopular why are
the Eagles so unpopular they are the
Jesse Waters of NFL football they are
vain uncouth loud aggressive vulgar and
dare I say repulsive and the same breath
I would say that Jesse Waters is the
Philadelphia Eagles a pundit tree in the
sense that even on their best day you
want them to lose so on the other hand
the Kansas City Chiefs yeah the Pete
hegseth of football you know prior to
the Midwest very good looking you know
very handsome selfless American how can
you not root for the Chiefs over the
Eagles when you think about hexes and
you think about Jesse Waters what are
you gonna pick oh going with the Eagles
and I have it on good authority that
they all love me not the defense the
offensive line really likes me I I want
to hear more about the controversy with
Bradley Cooper maybe you could do a deep
dive he's not even from Philly I think
he went to school outside of Philly or
grew up there and he did that movie he
did the movie you know some people say I
actually am more of a famous Eagles fan
than he is yeah some people say that
about Sylvester Stallone
some people
Andy Reid Andy Reid's got two teams
basically K sees his team now he's
winning against Philly Philadelphia
coach of all time obviously both teams
are playing then the Kelsey boys yeah
and we're going to blow them out
Kelsey boys I mean be a happy Mama
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now